les défis s'inscrivent dans un cadre
plus global que celui des trafics de
stupéfiants bien c'est mais bien celui
de la criminalité organisée dont la
direction nationale de la police
judiciaire est l'acteur majeur alors
première catégorie de défis des défis
numériques bien sûr avec les réseaux
sociaux qui servent à la fois de vitrine
pour le commerce de la drogue mais aussi
des vecteurs de communication pour pour
les organisations criminell pour les
trafiquants on recrute aujourd'hui de la
main d'œuvre sur les réseaux sociaux et
je pense que ce point-là est est
extrêmement important même si nous avons
développé les investigations sur les
réseaux sociaux je pense que il faut
encore aller au-delà de ce qu'il a de ce
qui a été mis en en place deuxème
catégorie de défis des défis
technologiques le directeur général tout
à l'heure a parlé de des cryptoonnaaies
des cryptoactifs le blanchiment à
travers ces à travers ces outils doit
être au cœur de nos préoccupations on
doit aussi faire évoluer euh nos modes
de travail aujourd'hui c'est c'est
c'estes avoirs là sontis sont
saisissables et sont saisis par par les
services les messageries
chiffrées on a tous en tête deux nom de
messageries chiffré qui ont qui ont
donné lieu à un important travail de la
France c'est encrechat et skycc ce sont
des messageries utilisées par les
groupes criminels quasiment
exclusivement utilisées par les groupes
criminels et notre rôle c'est d'être
toujours en avance de phase et d'essayer
de d'être positionné sur le nouvel outil
utilisé par les organisations
criminelles notre objectif c'est aussi
de lutter contre les contremesures qui
sont posées par par les les
organisations criminelles une cargaison
de cocaïne aujourd'hui elle est piégée
elle a des balises posées par les
organisations criminelles qui veulent
savoir où se situe où situe leurs
produits y compris quand il est dans un
container en pleine mer et qui fait une
traversée transatlantique